DEPARTME NASR.
>>> BURS "MYAKTHING ABOUE
GE OMICRON
LOS  CANNPYBALS HAG
MUTAONDL OULD CHANGE ID
N  THIS, HE HIS YEAR, FORM H PR
WE HAVSOHE VED AT THE MOMENTCADD
E RESTF
AND THINE  OF THRO % HE
BCCINATED.ANT ONLYE
IN THE WORLD'SSTRIESVED EVEN ONG
1.S OFCIBEF TI TO PUT ITTLY, O
OF THECOYTICS COMPANY AI2022, T
SURPLUS OF 818 VACCINES,S  MILLN
MOREES
FULLY VACCIN PINOSR.ED1 MILLIONE
TO BE TH A T E
HE NOT USED,
T THEYCKPILEILE TH6 BILLION E WT
5%THE INIS IS NOT F GLOB S VE SH
DONATIONS. INATH ORGBUT RICH COY
THE U.S. PLEDGED 1.2  SO R D ABO
THEU, ICELD NORWAY
EC
D ABOUT 112
CHINA HAS RECENTLY INCREASEDROMA
AS R OE K
OFALLING SHORT OE VACCINATING 4Y
COPUICH MEANS THRUS WI
D MUTATING
NOT SEE ANOTHER VARIANXT YEAATIT
IN YE IM
REASL THATCALC TLD02ON
BUT A E TO DO SO COU
LIT ANOTHER WAY,
06%OB
HAVE80TH
SELF-DESTRUCTIATSM AT  TE
THIC TOP IS
INFLATION AND WH I
FO SND BLAMEMINION'SID
ME
RO.KI RISING
AFLATAL C
GLOBAL INFLA?POLICIES LIKE P'S U
ADMINITIO LAAD S HAVE BEESIVELYE
Y BEGAG,NDPI A PUIN
BIDEN'S BUY AMERICAN
SAME THINGS.
ADDS IPTD
MAAV
FLRI LAST WEEK TLE
LUER FOFISHA
ORTHE
ARE MO.
THBEEN FELHEHE WORLDIL
WORKING  R
COUNTRIES THE MOST.
THOU GREATER
GLOBAL COOLI
D MO
DARE TO SAAT
GO TO CNN.COM FOA LINK TO MY
"WASHINGTON POST
AND LET'S GET STARTED.
>>> YOU W LET
BN OU
WARRIOR ANAND DIRE
N
ENANS PULAY NY IN THE COUNTRY,
E  STATEOW
SN'TO Y TR STOSPREAD?OU THINK I?
>> THEY DON'T BECAHIS QUITE
IT GOES AGAINST RITY  AT THBEGIF
S RESPONSRI AS
WELL AS UKTH
RA I THE 7JUST FEEREEV
APPLICATOF TBAING IMPO
IS ACA IAR I
THUR ON COUNTRIES FROM T
NORTH BECAUSEYBE.
EVENCCT A PCR TESTEINGIN MANY P
N PART D  LIKE U.S.
APPLYING THOSE PCULAR TR
BANS FARCU
>> IT WILL -- HAVE A CHILLINERRE
CAE WHAT HAPPENED  UBOTSWANA, SD
ME THEORE THISEW
NCERNED ABOUATD OBSLNT
SOAF BOTSWANA SHOULD
NOT SECRET WAY,
TIMELMA
THE CHLI RELATIO
OTS OF -- DEBATE
IT'S LE BESETHE COITULD BE SHHE
ICH WE WOR T OUR CCINESNG TACCET
F
AVNORTH,OUR PCR RESUS NOT PTED,E
SAY WHY BOTHERTI
WEBESOAND ERURURRGERTHOUGH, IS
BEE ICA, FOR  AT ONE POINT THE
RN SAIOPPPING US, WE HAVPRENOUG
PEOPLE WERG THSH
ISHE HESITANCYN EDY NDING OUT O
IT LIKELY MOREOMPLEX.E PERCENTAS
BASICALLY SAYING THE HAVTH IE LO
QUCENT STUDIES S
GREATE TINE AND GRVACCIN PARD
T HAVE SCIES E AV DRIPFED WITH
VACCINE SUPPLIES
A VACCINNCT-MOVING
ALMOST DAI B
ITADE MUCH HARDER
ANCLDEE OFTSUND  TOO.AND THAT IE
MESITANCY ANE O ESCATE
ST
MO
THEME  WEE.LLY IS AGAINST US.
HIIN THET  SHELVESARE -DEFEATIN.
ON